I have a lot of concerns with all things
I've seen online your relationship with
Carini was toxic at best Paul you
constantly accused her of cheating and
even asked for a DNA test when she
announced she was pregnant viewers
aren't too surprised that your marriage
hit a wall and you definitely
disrespected some of the many rules TLC
asked you to follow but according to you
and many other participants the show is
known for bending the truth but even
then we think we've seen enough to know
that there was trouble in paradise from
the get-go I just want talking body
where it has intimacy involved that's it
dozens of 90-day fiance participants
have struggled to follow the strict
rules TLC set out for them from filming
schedules and on-screen appearances to
criminal background checks and stress
management keep watching to find out
which rule proved to be the most
challenging one to follow if you agree
to join the cast of 90-day fiance you
have to welcome the camera crew with
open arms and let's face it that's not
always an easy thing to do when Jessie
Meester appeared on Cate KC's podcast he
revealed that the camera crew follows
the couples around for about 12 hours a
day over the span of two and a half
months but while some participants had
little issues being filmed for hours on
end some couples just couldn't handle it
some participants like Larissa were so
annoyed with the lack of privacy that
they often hid in the bathroom going as
far as to flush her wedding ring down
the toilet to make a statement that was
part of his love to her and she flushed
him down the toilet however hiding from
the cameras is against the rules
obviously everyone deserves a bathroom
break or two but disappearing in the
heat of the moment just isn't an option
participants can run if they don't mind
being followed but they certainly cannot
hide so what happens if a couple ends up
fighting once the camera crew leaves for
the day keep watching to find out
[Music]
this next virile might come as a
surprise because it proves that 90-day
fiance is staged from the get-go you
know how the participants sometimes meet
for the very first time at the airport
well this meeting is purely staged for
our entertainment as it turns out
couples cannot apply to a star on the
show if they have not met in person
within the last two years this is a
prerequisite when it comes to applying
for a k1 visa the US government cannot
approve a couples application if they've
never met in person I'm sweating to
death warned about this distance visa no
US citizens need to supply proof that
they've met their foreign partners
face-to-face or else they will not be
granted access into the country so to
appear on the show couples have to agree
to pretend to meet for the first time in
front of the cameras of course this rule
only applies to couples meeting on US
soil
we've been waiting so long and I was
just so happy easier the k1 visa process
has been designed to help star-crossed
lovers tie the knot and live together in
their country of choice but it's also
been designed to prevent tricksters from
entering the country some couples have
found out the hard way that just because
their k1 visa had been approved does not
mean that they will be granted access
into the u.s. before this can happen
each applicant must present themselves
to their embassy and complete an
in-depth interview this interview helps
officials ween out applicants with
ulterior motives
I don't want Louise to use this for a
pathway to citizenship once the
interview has been completed it is
uploaded on to government sites tell
plead their case couples can supply
embassy workers with photos plane
tickets messages and notarized letters
from family members swearing that their
relationship is authentic interviewers
can ask questions like how much money do
you make what is your favorite thing
about your partner what will you do if
your application gets denied and when
was the last time you saw your partner
in person once they get the green light
couples then have to complete an
in-depth interview with TLC but more on
that later a denial is always a
possibility
while some reality TV stars make a
boatload of money for appearing on TV
this is not
case for the cast of 90-day fiance even
with the show's huge following the us
participants made peanuts
despite airing their dirty laundry for
all to see what's worse is that
foreigners never see any return
seeing as it's illegal for TLC to pay
non-american residents before appearing
on the show TLC makes their payment plan
very clear us participants can make up
to a thousand dollars per episode and up
to $2,500 when they appear on the
tell-all special welcome to 90-day
fiance happily ever after however since
some couples are more popular than
others it's normal for participants to
ask for more money problem is they have
already signed a contract agreeing to
TLC's terms and more money just isn't an
option some couples like Angela and
Michael have appeared on more than one
season so TLC may offer them more money
for episode considering that they have a
huge following
however this money goes into Angela's
bank account and not Michaels because I
don't like depending on woman everyone
wants to look like a good guy but that's
not what reality TV is all about to keep
things interesting there needs to be a
villain but who would agree to come off
as the bad guy well the entire cast of
90-day fiance would before the couples
appear on the show they sign a contract
that stops them from suing TLC for
altering footage and creating fake
storylines so they're well aware that
they have to accept how they're
portrayed on TV her story doesn't match
up a reality that is just the truth but
it's all fun and games until
participants come face-to-face with
their TV counterparts this was a big
issue for Marc and Niki Shumaker who
attempted to sue TLC's parent company as
well as their production company after
they saw how they were portrayed on the
show Marc didn't like the fact that he
came off as an insulting and controlling
partner to Niki problem was they had
signed a contract that protected TLC
from getting sued for this exact reason
so their case was quickly thrown out I'm
sure that we're going to have issues
90-day fiance has a huge following of
dedicated fans and some of them happen
to be season trolls they're quick to
make assumptions and they love to throw
fuel on the fire especially on social
media participants have to grow a
backbone if they aspire to star on the
show but this can be a hard thing to do
when wanting to protect their images as
we all know 90-day fiance is notorious
for bending the truth but some fans do
not know this so they use social media
to send spiteful messages to whoever
comes off as a villain on the show fans
were quick to attack Mike and Natalie's
relationship online telling them that
they should call it quits and move on
these types of messages can seriously
mess with the well-being of a couple so
they're instructed to grow a backbone
and get over it
while some couples will go as far as to
delete their social media accounts to
escape the hate doing this isn't always
in their best interest after all posting
about your relationship can help
validate it helping participants get
their green card he has to bring all
kinds of documents what are the
advantages of appearing on 90 day fiancé
you ask well that's a great question
when you find out the answer let us know
because we aren't too sure ourselves you
would think that appearing on the show
would mean light a couple's k1 visa
process but that isn't the case as a
matter of fact couples are obligated to
complete their own visa applications
before starring on the show at this
point the US government has already
agreed to accept the immigration process
as long as the couples get married
before the 90 days are up walking
towards the altar is just to release TLC
takes no part in the rigorous
application process so the only
advantages of appearing on the show
revolve around media exposure and a low
pay grade the k1 visa process can take
months if not years to complete it is
for this reason that show runners tend
to poach participants by contacting
immigration attorneys who can refer them
couples who are nearing the end of the
lengthy process yeah I love cream car so
much
earlier on we mentioned that the camera
crew follows the couples around for
about 12 hours a day but who's to say
that things won't get hectic after the
camera crew retires for the evening some
couples keep their composure only to
blow up once no one is watching and the
cameramen and producers can pick up on
this the morning after participants are
made to talk about their previous night
together and disclose any fights or
arguments I think that he was completely
rude if the showrunners think that their
fight would make for a good episode they
can ask the participants to reenact them
however participants know all too well
that these fights can be revised and
scripted for dramatic effect so when
creating their contracts TLC makes sure
that participants are okay with scripted
scenes you have to think about future
getting married is a huge decision but
for some couples it's their only choice
if they fail to get married their non-us
partners will get sent back home it
takes a lot of work to get a k1 visa
approved so most of the time the
participants have already agreed to get
married before the 90 days is up this is
the beginning of the rest of our life
once they are legally married a green
card will be issued however this doesn't
guarantee a non-us participants stay in
the country the couple must remain
married for at least two years before
filing for divorce failing to do this
can result in the non-us partner facing
legal complications or deportation I
gave up to like almost everything in my
country 90-day fiance might be a
scripted show but that doesn't mean that
TLC aims to hire actors if there's one
thing they search for its authenticity
while conducting interviews show runners
look for participants who have real-life
problems and struggles they also
performed thorough background checks
before accepting any candidates although
it's an ugly truth show runners would
rather cast couples who have conflicting
morals criminal backgrounds and money
issues if I can't provide
I'm working with you all this because it
makes for a better TV TLC doesn't want
to cast picture-perfect lovers instead
they aim to cast couples who come with
extensive baggage most of the time TLC
knows about a participant's criminal
history before they had time to come
clean about it to their fiance if
couples aren't authentic during the
casting interviews they won't make it
onto the show I have reviewed your your
record and that's a rat before you go
tell us which couple you're currently
rooting for in the comments below and be
sure to tell us what you thought about
these 10 strict rules while you're at it
you have not been an active partner
spouse to me since we got married give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe for more thanks for
watching the things we'll see you soon
you